it makes who think what was up on the
vault in it they give us what they did
like what they don't wanna know if we
don't come out I'll never bored . remain
is very simple creatures we just want to
remain britain is tearing itself apart
over brexit democracy's dead I'm not
gonna vote because I vote in it didn't
can't this government needs to be honest
with the British people and they're not
and that is a massive problem three
years on from the referendum and Britain
still hasn't left what happens when the
majority don't get what they voted for
we've got open rebellion
it's literally open rebellion against
the people the very pillars of our
democracy government Parliament the
courts now going head-to-head what's at
stake if a brexit deal can't be struck
as the possibility that that piece is
going to be broken by a return to
checkpoints Britain is is broken I'm not
sure that everything can be put back
together again
[Music]
no ever since the referendum there have
been people protesting outside the
Parliament on both sides of the debate
and there are determined committed lot
and I think it's a good place to start
people asked me who I'm gonna vote [ __ ]
out I've no idea why should I vote why
should I respect anybody else's vote in
future when they don't respect mine from
the 23rd of June 2016
democracy's dead I'm not gonna vote
because I vote in it didn't count I'm
some sort of second-class citizen who
doesn't count it's so soon it's it's
more serious than brexit do we have
democracy in this country or not and my
understanding is no we don't I
understand that a single person might
have known what they voted for but get
any too remote to leave voters next to
each other they're not necessarily going
to agree you get to remain it's together
they're going to agree we just want to
remain I wanted to know more about the
protesters and what drives them to stand
here all day
[Music]
so I have a loud voice and you know I'm
not afraid to use it democracy is all
about drawing a line in the sand and
this is about democracy now and the
banner is just so another way of
reinforcing it the simple placard the
simple message is what what gets over
and I've got an old bit of timber lying
around in there in the stables and the
the marker it needs to be black it needs
to be simple it needs to be as wide as
possible pop along to the local art shop
and see what they've got job done you
enter the debate there is no greater
disloyalty than the elected class
ignoring the will of the people you know
it was a clear majority to leave the EU
and they are doing their damnedest to
not leave the EU that's that's
disloyalty of the highest order
I don't normally dress up in a in a
crazy costume but what else is there to
do what else is there to do we need our
voices heard and and the
parliamentarians need to hear that
there's passion out there
Jeff isn't alone we've carried out a
national poll asking if people have
faith in Parliament after brexit 75
percent said faith in Parliament had
been damaged
lot number 207 we have the docs
watercolor picture baby curry nice one
again soppy a fight [ __ ] in 308 fries
with you your bit at 3 in advance or
three that sense of disillusionment in
Parliament is being felt right across
the UK places like Port Talbot in Wales
voted out while the Labour MP here voted
to remain truth is many leave voters
here expected to have left by now the
first person I meet at this auction is
an Beynon who voted leave we don't come
out I'll never bought full stop
definitely and I think a lot of people
feel the same way so as I say I don't
know where it's gonna end but it's just
a mess they want this to both again
again if you can't honor the first one
no I'm not interested in voting again
and as I said if we don't come out
I'll never bought again as I was laid by
I get chatting to Steve Jones he tells
me he'll never vote labour again either
it makes you think what was the point of
all tenor
do you only mean what was the point of
end so all in all you feel like you feel
like the MPs have obviously they all
have an age you know I mean you're
acting like a lot of kids up and we're
so instead you see another night show
you this pathetic don't only mean we
don't understand we do understand of
your love it
I like the MPs but
they give us of what they did like the
mob they don't want it it's it's a few
that I hear all over the place I mean
this guy can hardly contain his his
anger he voted he says to leave he
believes he's been absolutely ignored by
MPs says they're taking that the mick
out of him and you see you see the anger
that gentlemen like that are expressing
all across this area all across this
part of Wales we asked people if they
thought their MP was doing a good or bad
job reflecting their views on brexit
most 41% said they thought their MP was
doing a bad job with only 1/4 thinking
they were doing a good job it's clear
that brexit has driven a wedge between
MPs and some of their constituents with
Parliament unlawfully suspended the
Labour MP here Stephen Kinnick is back
on his patch kennix caught between his
constituents and his own party trying to
please both he wants labour to
renegotiate a deal and respect the
referendum result and so I wanted to
talk to him about some of the things his
constituents had told me should they
trust you well I think if those who look
at the way that the Labour Party has
shifted towards a second referendum
position we'll have seen that I have not
shifted at all I am saying exactly the
same thing now as I was three years ago
after the referendum result and so I
hope my constituents will say well he is
actually prepared to swim against the
tide he's prepared not to who don't have
a choice don't here you've got no choice
but to to face this community and say
look my party might be pretty much a
romaine party now but listen guys I'm
not I'm with you I mean it's a fight for
survival for MPs like you I I am saying
to you hand on
heart that even if my constituency had
voted remain I would be taking the
position that I do because I'm a
Democrat and I play like believe in
playing by the rules I don't think that
it's healthy at all for our democracy to
hit the people against Parliament in
that way because then it's no longer a
debate about policies and about what
people stand for it's about who you are
and what is your identity much of the
anger I saw here in Wales was over
Parliament's handling of brexit but
elsewhere if Westminster can't get
brexit right they run the risk of
opening up old wounds
[Music]
this is the unresolved issue in brexit
the UK government is under a lot of
pressure to come up with an approach to
avoid a hard border between Northern
Ireland and the Republic of Ireland if
the UK leaves the EU without a deal it's
so sensitive here because people know
what border checks can lead to the IRA
coming to our home they held us hostage
agree of both Bloody Sunday and marches
and demonstrations my heroes were the
IRA at midnight at the broad Patsy I'm
here and he said cabarrus and he said
don't worry girl I'll be home soon
everything will be all right
our enemies with the the loyalist
community and in my ace sort of
everybody was against us he was chained
to a van loaded with 1200 pounds of
explosives he was used to a human bomb
the age of 18 it was approached by some
budding you to become a Republican
activist and at that time I didn't
hesitate I said yes I had to tell my 18
year old son on the phone noted murdered
his daddy
mrs. okay yeah
Kathleen and Anne have struck up the
most unlikely friendship and I've come
to meet them here because I want to
understand their concerns I don't want
to go back to heaven des open me Burton
open me Barnett and let them check it
out just just to go on a visit you know
and then when you look at the way my
husband's death was the check point was
at the border do you think enough
consideration was given to happen
absolutely not I don't think any
consideration must give them really
whatsoever
and and even though you at this late
stage people still people in England
Scotland and Wales only know butts and
pieces what they've heard them you use
they haven't loved here they don't know
what it's been like it's very very
fragile do you have faith in Parliament
and also and also in the background that
I grew up and I never had faith in an in
Parliament that was sitting in
Westminster but what is making this a
but more worrying is the possibility
that that piece is going to be broken by
a return to checkpoints
anin kathleen to remarkable women who
have first-hand knowledge of what can
happen in communities when divisions are
put in place when checkpoints are put in
place and they are now looking to
Westminster for answers about what the
Irish border might look like after
brexit
[Music]
having voted to remain in the EU we face
know been taking out against our will
[Music]
there are some signs that all the antics
down in Westminster could be changing
opinion amongst some people here in
Scotland just look at some recent
opinion polls and you'll see that one
big issue one that had arguably gone a
bit quiet over the last few years could
be making a comeback now the last three
years have shown beyond any doubt that
for Scotland the Westminster system is
broken and you know what else has been
broken the promises Westminster made to
the people of Scotland they have been
broken to the Scottish nationalists
cibrex it as their second bite and
independence a chance to make a run for
it
I feel that breaks it's exposed fissures
and cracks that were there already and
it's it's made them wider but it shone a
light on them in a way that I think
everybody in the whole of the UK know
has to recognize that we want different
things we want to go in different
variations I've come to see Karen
Campbell an ex-cop now author sick of
Westminster and sick of brexit for me in
Scotland what's happening at Westminster
probably always was a bit chaotic but
it's it's showing it up for what it is
it's illuminated it really brightly that
I guess rather than people seeing or
should have got me independent it's no a
case for thinking what is there left for
us in Britain white why should be Steve
what is Scotland's future if whatever we
revolt will always be disregarded and
then something as major as this
constitutional change we just have to
suck up and go along with with what our
larger neighbor South have chosen with
people pulling in different directions
the main political parties are now
gearing up for a general election we
asked if an election would solve brexit
the majority 53% didn't think a general
election was the answer
but an election is coming it's not if
but when the result of that election
will tell the story of where the United
Kingdom is right now and where it is
heading
you